Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
I've been writing all morning so I'm just
kinda out of it.
I've been writing almost every day since I
got back from the Paper Towns set, and as
much as I do enjoy spending 18 hours a day,
six days a week trying to figure out precisely
what an Executive Producer is supposed to
do, I definitely like writing even more.
Like, it's just such a massive relief to even
temporarily feel like you can escape the prison
of your consciousness, you know?
But I'm just kind of out of it 'cause I'm
kind of in the story and not really here.
But anyway, today's video comes to you in
two parts:
Part one.
A Decade.
Hank, it has been ten years since my first
novel Looking for Alaska was published.
As nerdfighter Temerity Jane pointed out on
Twitter that means that Looking for Alaska
is now like a fifth grader.
Looking For Alaska isn't just potty trained
it can like make itself a grilled cheese for
lunch and read books.
Looking For Alaska potentially could read
Looking for Alaska, although I would not recommend
it.
By the way, Hank, you might know nerdfighter
Temerity Jane as the person whose marriage
proposal I participated in many years ago?
John: Will you marry him?
Kelly: Holy...
Yes!
John: YEAH!
SHE SAID YES!
HUZZAH!
Kelly: Oh my god, I don't even have pants
on.
John: GAHHH!
Well, Hank, not only are she and nerdfighter
Phil now married, they in fact have a child.
A tiny little nerdfighter.
God, we're getting old.
But I just feel so incredibly lucky and grateful
that this little book has hung around for
so long.
And as of today, Hank, there is a brand new
super fancy edition of Looking for Alaska
with fifty pages of bonus content and really,
really nice paper.
Hank, as you know, I'm something of a book
making nerd, and nothing against the original
Looking for Alaska with the candle cover that
I didn't like because this is cigarette smoke
not candle smoke, and its cheap paper and
its inexpensive binding.
But Hank, I always dreamed that when I had
a book come out it would have this thing.
You see that thinG up there?
That black and white thing?
That little thing is astonishingly expensive,
but it is my favorite thing in books.
Also it's got this beautiful cover designed
by Rodrigo Corral and these great end papers
he designed.
At the beginning it says "I go to seek a great
perhaps," which were the last words of François
Rabelais, and at the end it says "How will
I ever get out of this labyrinth?"
which were the last words of Simón Bolívar.
It's also got a new introduction from me,
a bunch of deleted and revised scenes from
the book to give people a sense of how Julie
and I worked on it together, a retrospective
essay by the great YA lit scholar Michael
Cart, and like thirty pages of me answering
the questions that readers have asked me most
over the years.
But mostly it's just like the physical object
of my dreams.
So yeah, this is in bookstores now, but mostly
ten years later I just wanted to say thank
you.
Part two.
The 2014 Project for Awesome.
So Hank, this year, half the Project for Awesome
raised money for Save the Children and Partners
in Health.
That part raised over $700,000 for those two
great organizations.
And then the second part of the Project for
Awesome raised money for charities chosen
by nerdfighteria.
And today I get to announce what those charities
are.
The top ten charities according to your votes
at projectforawesome.com will receive $25,000
each, and they are:
Not Forgotten, which works with orphans in
Peru.
The Harry Potter Alliance, which works to
decrease world-suck in all kinds of ways around
the world.
The Office of Letters and Light, which runs
NaNoWriMo.
The Thirst Project, a water charity.
This Star Won't Go Out, which provides direct
support to families of kids living with cancer.
Doctors Without Borders, which provides, you
know, doctors without borders.
Days for Girls International, which works
to provide feminine hygiene products and sexual
education to girls around the world.
She's the First, which is dedicated to girls'
education in the developing world.
Pencils for Kids, which, you know, brings
pencils to kids.
And
Ultimate Peace, an organization that uses
Ultimate Frisbee to facilitate relationships
between Israelis and Palestinians.
Smaller grants, but still over $10,000 will
go to the next ten charities chosen by nerdfighteria
which are:
We Need Diverse Books
The American Foundation for Suicide Prevention
The Book Truck
To Write Love on Her Arms
Donate Life
Garczyńska's Foundation
Books for Africa
Stella's Circle
Water.org and
The Sound of Hope.
These twenty charities are going to use our
money to decrease worldsuck in lots of ways.
It's just awesome.
Thank you.
OK now I'm going to go back to writing, Hank,
because I miss it.
By the way, Hank, I hear on Tumblr that you
are also writing a story.
This is how I find out about things in my
brother's life now.
Tumblr.
But seriously, Hank, can you believe it's
been ten years?
I mean, this book is older than YouTube!
It's older than some of the people watching
this video.
Ah!
That didn't go particularly well.
I'll see you on Friday.